25c evaluate the trend in Part B so that
chain being convergence evaluate that
trend with respect to the economic and
technical feasibility factors okay now
before I finish look at that end of the
sentence what does it say the factors
that must be considered not by us
viewers but by content creators and
publishers okay so if you look to look
at your airtime and see who it relates
to is it talking about the viewers at
home or the end-user right if you did
that then you miss the question the
question says content creators and
publishers so put yourself in the shoes
of someone who like an independent
filmmaker or something like that okay
they're the person who you're trying to
think about and trying to channel and
you figure out technical feasibility and
economic feasibility so let me give you
some aspects underneath these headings
think about technical feasibility right
well creators have to produce content
that's increasingly high quality right
so professional audio professional video
collecting hardware because you've got
to match the capabilities of the devices
and the hardware that you're gonna be on
right does that make sense
so you can't just get away with cheap
quality videos and that's why I have to
use things like a mic because if I did
it and you listen to it you're like man
this is terrible I expect better for my
YouTube viewing experience okay so
that's a technical feasibility issue
which the content creator has to think
about I've got to have really
high-quality technical equipment right
secondly most people got this one
publishers publishers not the content
creators but publishers because
publishers are second separate group of
people who I mentioned the question
they've got a syndicate or distribute
content to an increasing number of
formats right things that just get
released on DVD anymore you've got to
have it in DVD and blu-ray and
in addition and for YouTube and for the
cinema all these different formats that
publishers the person who's got to worry
about that right so you've got to think
about okay it's gonna get delivered to
TVs and PCs and tablets and smartphones
and I've got to work out how to make all
of that happen okay
so one of the things you can put under
here I suppose is different formats
different form factors so I'm people are
watching on screens this big that was
crazy this big and so on okay so that's
things that the publishers have to worry
about okay what about economic what
about the money side of things so think
about things that cost more and things
that cost less that's a that's an easy
way of thinking about the economic
feasibility okay so what some examples
okay things are cost more number one it
costs more to produce content for
multiple platforms that's what we were
just talking about here okay what in
spending extra money to make your stuff
available for us different platforms
he's the economic benefit right you're
gonna get more viewers you're gonna get
a broader viewership right so that might
be if you got a broad audience you can
make more money off it so that's kind of
you got economic feasibility both ways
okay secondly I if you're releasing
something on YouTube think about the
costs that are involved versus if you
wanted to release something on the
silver screen which do you think is more
expensive question guys is it more
expensive to release a movie say on
YouTube or is it more expensive to
release it to cinemas cinemas right now
here's the thing that's actually really
good for really small creators because
you know say I want to make a movie and
I just got some basic equipment I would
never be able to get something on a
cinema screens internationally right
because it requires hundreds of millions
of dollars but you want to put something
out on YouTube I can do without just you
know a few hundred or three thousand
dollars worth of equipment okay so that
means there's the possibility for
content creators okay of producing
smaller projects tougher avenues like
this like YouTube
okay so the you can actually make things
which are smaller and they have niche
appeal right if you're going to put
something out to the movies because it
cost hundreds of millions of dollars it
has to be popular enough to write so if
you're pitching it to the pawn shop
right suppose Steve's got this awesome
idea
he's like I've got a great idea it's
gonna be cause Steve's awesome movie
okay and it's gonna be about following
me Steve around for a day okay and you
just get to it's a 24 hour movie it's
gonna be great
fine I'll just be sleeping but anyway
you know I think it's great and you can
have that just Steve standing there
pitching that to the executives they're
like you don't know he's gonna be all
that popular don't overly kind of commit
money to that so that is it sorry Steve
so you know it's not just there may be
anyone you know 24-hour be too boring be
too too but there will be you know maybe
there are thousand people all over the
world which is not that many people who
are actually really interested in
Steve's 24 hours story right now there's
1,000 people aren't enough to make a
commercially viable
you know big movie singer production
what Steve complete is 24 hour video up
on YouTube and he might get like you
know 2,000 views and you know you can
make a few dollars for that okay so
things with niche appeal right niche and
I see a change right there very specific
audience you can get up on YouTube and
that's fine right if people are
interested in it even if there's a very
small amount they'll watch okay so
that's really that's a big economic
advantage for creators okay what other
things are there well you've got this
increased ease of content piracy people
mention this okay so because you've got
freely available software to rip DVD's
things like handbrake handbrake is the
neighbor a piece of software you can
just take it every day unless it's got
really sophisticated encryption on it
you can just download it okay and you
can turn it into something that's very
easy to distribute you can make a tyrant
put it up somewhere and it's really hard
to police okay so that's a disadvantage
that you need to think about you need to
right there do I want to put my video up
on my film up on YouTube because once I
do that they wouldn't just download and
give it to where they like right so
that's a danger right now
I've got a few more points but the I
think that's enough and the key is that
you need to evaluate right so you can't
just say look here the point is but
here's what is it generally good or is
it generally bad make add value call
okay evaluate need some criteria to
judge whether this is worthwhile lashes
Steve that's great